so when you're first throwing on a pair
of jumping stilts I would say definitely
be beside a building or beside a fence
you'll strap up not a problem and when
you stand up you're gonna feel awkward
there's no normal feeling about being on
stilts and you just need to hold on it
Finn's walk normal and guarantee within
5 10 minutes you'll be walking around by
yourself and get used to it bounce side
to side and on both feet you'll get very
used to still try not to think about
your own stilts look forward to like
you're walking normal when you first buy
them the screens will be stiff you won't
bounce very high but as you get
comfortable weeks go by they'll get worn
in and you'll be flying in no time this
is the velocity still through still
works incorporated in Las Vegas and it
is made with a t6 aluminum which has
about 4,000 weight opposed to the 2,000
weight of the lower-end stilts it has a
tightly woven fiberglass spring that's
given me 95% of what I put into it so
launching me easily 6 to 10 feet in the
air it's got a great calf cup wrapped
around your calf holds you tight opposed
to every other still this is the best
built on market and it's ranging from
two thousand to three thousand dollars